President Trump is openly accusing
senior law enforcement officials of
outright bias he tweeted this morning
quote the top leadership and
investigators of the FBI and the Justice
Department have politicized the sacred
investigative process in favor of
Democrats and against Republicans
he added rank and file are great people
now the president spoke out before an
expected decision to allow the release
of a classified memo produced by the
Republican chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee it claims the FBI
abused surveillance during its
investigation of possible ties between
the Trump campaign and Russia the bureau
says it has grave concerns about the
memos accuracy major Garrett is at the
White House major good morning good
morning the White House dismisses rumors
that FBI director Christopher Rea
threatened to quit over this entire memo
controversy those close to Ray tell us
that's simply not his style but they
also tell us that Ray may issue a
rebuttal if as expected
this Republican drafted memo is released
later today as president Trump flew back
to Washington yesterday a senior
official on Air Force One told reporters
the White House would not object to the
memos release the president is ok with
it the official said I doubt there will
be any reductions then it is in
Congress's hands after that that
contradicted other White House sources
who said parts of the memo would be
redacted
FBI director Christopher Ray has fought
against its release arguing the GOP
drafted memo unfairly criticizes the
bureau with cherry-picked information
written by House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez the memo according
to those who have read it alleges the
FBI and Justice Department did not
follow proper procedures when seeking a
secret surveillance warrant of Trump
campaign official Carter page in 2016 it
was revealed Wednesday that Nunez edited
the memos contents after the
Intelligence Committee voted to
declassify it and before it was sent to
the White House for review House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi called for
Nunez to be removed saying in a letter
to House Speaker Paul Ryan quote
newness is deliberately dishonest
actions make him unfit to serve as
chairman I think they're just playing
politics and Ryan said the memo is not
an attack on the FBI but a check on
power if American Civil Liberties were
were abused then that needs to come to
light so that that doesn't happen again
the president has tracked conversation
about this memo on television for weeks
and sees it as potential reinforcement
of a long-standing contention that some
in the FBI were biased against his
campaign those familiar with the memo
Nora tell us it's not nearly as
explosive as some of the descriptions
mr. Trump saw on television all right
major thank you